[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here so like
clockwork every year before a new
smartphone a new big phone comes out we
get a bunch of renders and leaks and
sometimes models of that phone as a sort
of a sneak peek to what we're going to
get that happened with the new pixel
that happened with the new iPhone every
year and Samsung's no exception and one
of the most tangible forms of that is
the dummy models that case makers used
to prototype their designs and
dimensions of the new phones that we can
actually get our hands on a couple weeks
before the actual phone came out I've
done videos with models of the iPhone
before the iPhone actually comes out
gets us a pretty good look so from that
same source we have one of the most
anticipated and hyped phones of the year
coming up for 2019 that would be the
Samsung Galaxy S 10 and I can say models
plural because they are going to be at
least three phones this year at least
and these two represent the main ones
the Galaxy S 10 and the Galaxy S 10 plus
so these types of videos always have an
expiration date because in a few weeks
we're gonna know exactly what the phone
looks like anyway and then we can get to
it but that's never stopped anybody from
taking a look beforehand so this is
everything that I've learned from these
models so first of all like I said we're
actually expecting at least three phones
and that would be galaxy s 10 galaxy s
10 plus and then a galaxy s 10 e or s 10
light sort of a lightweight model so the
S 10 being the standard 6.1 inch display
thirty five hundred million power
battery and the S 10 plus being the
bigger brother the six point four four
inch display and possibly a four
thousand milliamp hour battery and then
the S 10 light is likely going to be
somewhere a bit smaller in size about a
five point eight inch screen I don't
have a model of it but you know slightly
different shape and look from the
renders the single camera instead of
multiple I think you could basically
describe it as Samsung's answer to the
iPhone 10 arm and also always the more
phones you add the more stratification
there is in the lineup the more there is
to remember but the main thing I think
to remember is going to be they're all
gonna be different prices so S 10 light
being somewhere around 800 to 850
dollars which is not cheap at all but
then s 10 coming in at around a thousand
and Galaxy S 10 plus coming in at around
1100 bucks starting then going all the
way up to possibly a terabyte model
that's around two thousand US dollars
so these are not cheap phones very
premium prices and we may also see in
the lineup two others a super budget or
more cheap version of the phone that we
don't know as much about and also
possibly a folding phone so they could
show off five phones in the next two
weeks maybe but here's what I learned
from the models of the s10 and the s10
plus so in the hand they definitely
still feel like Samsung phones and they
look like him right so they're still
familiar
nothing super drastic here it's still
going to be glass on the back and even
though these models aren't glass they're
fingerprint magnets already with that
smooth flat back and they still have a
second specialty button on the left side
under the volume rocker that will
probably be an unchangeable big sweet
button again what I can say is it feels
more like a mini Note 9 than a larger s9
and I mean just because it's a little
bit boxy ER with a little bit more
square of a corner radius so it just
kind of looks more like a note than an S
but then it still has very thin side
bezels this holds up with what we've
seen in the renders the infinity edge
display is still taken to the absolute
maximum and on the back placement wise
looks like the fingerprint sensor will
probably be the biggest question still
it looks to me like the back of the
phone here is now just the cameras the
flash and then the biometrics like the
heart rate sensor etc and the
fingerprint reader will be underneath
the glass of the display but obviously
that and the hole punch cameras are the
things you can't really tell from the
case mock-ups but you can see actually
that they did include the dual cameras
versus the single cameras so single
front-facing camera on the s10 and dual
front-facing cameras on the s10 plus so
we're thinking it gets a regular selfie
camera and a super wide-angle selfie
camera like the pixel three has right
now which I love and it also shows a
triple rear cameras on both the s10 and
the s10 plus so one standard camera one
telephoto camera and then one super wide
angle camera like we saw with the LG
already this year and we have rumored of
course for the new iPhones as well
definitely hoping for that but actually
think I think it's gonna end up being
dual cameras on the s10 and triple
cameras on the s10 plus I hope I'm wrong
I hope they don't hobble the smaller
phone I hope they put all the same stuff
in both but that's what I think it's
gonna end up being so we have the screen
going all the way to the sides we have
the bezels on the
top and the bottom going almost again
right up to the edge and then the
earpieces now a sort of this slot at the
very very top of the phone I mean
Samsung never really seems to take
speakers super seriously they never go
super hard with the audio but you can
still see it does keep that headphone
jack and I think this may be the last
year Samsung keeps it around so if
you're dead set on keeping a headphone
jack in your next phone this is probably
going to be the only flagship option
available for you this or maybe the next
Galaxy Note and overall just feel on the
hand I like it I've liked Samsung phones
the way they feel in the past the great
displays the boxy metal and glass build
this feels familiar and the smaller
phone is still pretty small still bigger
than the small iPhone but it still feels
compact mostly because it's such a
narrow aspect ratio like we've seen
before but yeah that's essentially where
we're at all we really have to do now is
wait for the phone to actually be
revealed and you know you can expect a
video on that when it finally does go
live the event is February 20th but my
question to you is what do you think of
this design that's pretty much gonna
rule 2019 with the hole punch display I
mean personally for this exact phone
what I'm looking most forward to is the
cameras hopefully they upgrade them to
be competitive with the pixel hopefully
there's a nitesite competitor versions
of that hopefully the dual front-facing
cameras are of the super wide and the
regular like I've seen so that enough
plus one you I would make me consider
really liking this phone but what do you
think what are you excited for about
Galaxy S 10 let me know either way
thanks for watching
stop see the next one peace
[Music]